foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Hue Boutique and all purchases go right
to benefiting new exhibitions and
programs at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American cop as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that all also include
over 2 000 chess lectures for anyone to
enjoy become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family-friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 150 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
it's 2023 and the grand chest tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
sagreb Croatia for the first two rapping
in Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
Welcome to our broadcast for the 2023
spring chess classic my name is Julian
perlaco and I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster Tata of abrahamian Tata why
don't you take us through the standings
for the uh A and B group welcome
everyone thank you for joining us for
another round of the spring classic
before we get started let's take a look
at where we are in the standings let's
start with the group a where there
haven't been any changes in the
standings as all the games yesterday
ended in a draw so we still have a
four-way tie for first between some
Savion Darius swedes Christopher you and
Jasper quesada with aliens Nick and
Daniel TARTA chasing them by half a
point
and in group b we still have a soul
leader gargle Contour as in that
heartbreaking game Akshay Chandra
he was he was cruising to in the game
and he had a winning position but
unfortunately in a key moment he didn't
find a important idea and the game ended
in a draw which left Contour in the
first place and he's being chased by
half a point by four players bambasuring
batsurin Victor michalevsky who won his
game yesterday Felix bobberger and
akshat Chandra who is still half a point
behind let's take a look at the
tournament format so the players are
playing game in 90 with a 30 second
increment for the first 40 moves then
they will get an additional 30 minutes
after move 40 with a 30 second increment
throughout the entire game and the
schedule for um for the games is they
will be starting at 1 pm Central
Standard time we will be coming to you
every every day at 4pm Standard Time uh
three hours after the start of each
round
let's take a look at the pairing so we
can start looking at the games so we
have several key matchups of the day so
as I've been looking from a corner of my
ass to the position we have several
games that actually one game might be
reaching
um we might be having a result soon but
our key matchup of the day is between
Dyer sweets and Jasper quesada so let's
jump right into this game and let's take
a look at what is going on so currently
we have an end game we're on move 23 and
white flare has 12 minutes black player
was as 38 minutes and what are your
first impression of this position
um well why why does that material so I
guess I like white but uh it doesn't
seem trivial at all I'm not not entirely
sure how I would proceed with white uh
so let's do a summary of the position so
a lot of a lot of things are hanging so
first thing I notice is of course the
material and the second thing is the
opposite color Bishops and we saw
yesterday a game with opposite color
Bishops that were still Rooks and
knights on the board eventually that
game ended in a try it was Christopher
used game he didn't manage to convert
his Advantage so here there's this
tension of the knights the knights are
hanging and of course the second thing
that stands out to me are these deep
ponds which is a matter of which pun
will be weaker because if this Knights
are traded off the spawns are traded off
okay there's a lot of ifs then I think
if okay if I take some before then
immediately this Pawn will fall there's
no way to defend this every single black
piece is attacking this Pawn
and if this also get uh traded then
we'll have four versus three with double
pawns but again the presence of The Rook
Rooks to make a big difference as white
can still play and push for an advantage
and another thing that stands out to me
is this king and the back rank so if we
start moving Rooks to the back rank this
might become problematic yeah would you
consider a move like Bishop D7 here to
protect the B5 Knight and maybe try to
play Rook C8 or uh what oh actually I
see the issue with that yeah Knight to
D3 attacks F2 and C1 so that would
probably be a mistake yeah so the bishop
box
stay here with the idea of 93 so what
our white option options if not taken
before
uh can I move my knight yes that will be
the second logical question yeah I was
concerned if we moved the Knight then
black would just take on A3 so black
does have a lot of seems like a lot of
activity in this position so for example
if I challenge this Rook because Rook A2
is coming and I don't want to allow that
so let's say I challenge the rook and
this actually might end in a very funny
Perpetual if you go with this rock
because I'm constantly actually here I'm
not threatening Rook C2
so here you can go Knight P5 and perhaps
Rook C4 but Roxy four wheeler roll
so we have to think about how many Rooks
we want to trade and in this kind of
positions in general in end games you
always want to think about what pieces I
want to keep but pieces I want to trade
if trading a pair of rocks good for
white or good for black I think black
wants to keep their Rooks on
it does appear we have a move in the
game I'm not sure what Dara Plato looks
like he played something to the back
rank oh he played the movie Rook to C8
okay so it makes sense yeah I think this
bishop I guess his intention after Rook
B5 is just to play a takes uh B4 because
otherwise you're data piece right
um and here yeah I guess Bishop H7 is
the trick oh
um
yes okay let's say so maybe you just
don't have time right like if I play
Rook D1 then so if I play here Rook d8
perhaps
and the frog picture get one and you
grab and now you will be up
well okay this one I can always win back
but now you're up four versus two that's
a lot yeah
after Rook C8
okay so Bishop 87 is a threat so I need
to defend so G6
where does this uh Bishop cannot go on
this diagonal I think this still runs
into problems maybe we can still take on
B4 but then yeah it's not so clear how
we're gonna defend everything after Rook
B5
so maybe we don't need
oh you want to play rookie one you want
D1 it doesn't matter right so one way
okay so if you take I'm I'm thrilled
about this because
okay yeah what is this constructed like
my Pawn structure I have very secure
Pawn structure so as long as I don't let
you double somehow I'm very happy and
something will fall here I think it
might be getting mated as well
well if you go here you'll get mated
yeah I agree
so we don't go there but okay so let's
say I go rookie one probably black will
play King to G7 but then maybe you'll go
rookie it anyway
and how do I defend my Bishop okay so
maybe the idea is which could have
happened from G takes F5 here here and
maybe Knight D3
but here I'm so nervous about this King
because your check is just one check
whereas my check might be right so let's
say I go here
you check
I think you have an amazing resource
oh no I'm getting mated to the same
tactic Rook A3 and what's this me yeah
you Rook H2 and then um Rook G's three
can F5 Rook H5 is mate yeah amazing
amazing
I have to go back and now you capture
and again you're threatening mates
and actually am I losing here
so I don't want to go here because this
will be same made we just saw so I have
to go here
and this actually might be some kind of
one you're chasing me to safety yeah
like Teenage five and then after you
take King G4 and the King will happily
live on the F3 Square I think
yeah and then rogator is coming and meet
how did we land here so we went to six
and after G6 so Roxy so we said G6
because Bishop H7 is a threat so G6 is
not so much attack on the bishop okay it
is an attack on the bishop but also
defense against Bishop 87 and now we're
thinking rookie one so it doesn't matter
if we start which it takes F5 or um King
G7 it's all a transposition but since I
have King G7 in my line so I'll go this
way to takes up five and we set Knight
D3
right so what did we do here we went 96
so maybe I should start checking you so
check
so at least I have a perpetual
right but probably probably we want more
than that here right like maybe Rook is
where was our Rook before it was on C8
okay so Rook C6 King E7 Rook C7 if you
go to F6 can I play Knight D6 there
because now I'm tickets
can get six and now you have too many
problems
but maybe 98 is a threat but um so here
you're actually attacking F7 so maybe
your Cafe
so
yeah we will always have Perpetual with
Rook F7 but
I don't know how we're going to convert
this if you like Rook takes B5 here can
we do any better than Perpetual yeah I
was also just thinking I kind of left my
night hanging
yeah
yeah it's very bizarre obviously we have
the um the bar so we know that White's
doing really well here but not entirely
sure how
so I'm assuming okay I shouldn't assume
I should calculate right I'm a
commentator
so check uh we have Rook G3 here oh
that's that's nice
because I thought I'm wait is this
losing
uh yeah because Rook H2 Rook G3 and I
collect the Rook on G8 I think
sure
but I'm convinced
no I'm okay again I'm getting committed
is this mate
no
no I don't think this is made yeah I
I don't know but it's it's uh this is a
great resource
okay so in this position I can actually
go
to
um H3 which means you cannot take with
the Rook the Knight D6 what about King
D7 here why is it so easy for for white
I wasn't this was the move I was
concerned about
um
okay so you're attacking both so I
cannot
let me jump so I have to defend my my
look doesn't have any of
so I have to play only move
and now if you take oh now I can block
if you do this
this is still mate oh the king's not
there we can run to F6 okay okay that's
that's nice so we're just up a piece in
this line
check then I take this
especially this will be made
oh this is actually a really nice made
it's aesthetically pleasing
so
so maybe it okay so maybe my best
counter plays to take with the Knight so
now I'm threatening Knight G4 and Knight
E4 so maybe trying to create some kind
of a mating net
so you will check me my only score is
here and this looks like a mating net
but I don't we have a knife
we don't need a meeting that
well not a rook but okay yeah one
distance this is the falls apart this is
not the worst exchange to have so what
to do after Rook C8 okay but now now we
have this thread so yeah okay I think I
think we figured out why white is doing
I'm doing well this Rook C7 Knight B7
stuff is
it's probably a WebEx position is
collapsing but this is very concrete so
so besides G6 with other moves that's
black cap so do your other move you
either have to take
or you have to go G6 yeah so why not
take on B5 and then when you take on B4
then play the move G6 it would take on
before then we go rookie one
yeah I think we took on B4 last time
yeah we took one before okay this is
what we did so maybe G6 here yeah
and now if the bishop oh this is kind of
an unfortunate Square because after you
take on D4 you'll hit my Bishop
so maybe here also I have to go Rook
um I don't know if it makes a difference
but King so I I don't think you I think
we saw a version of this right right
this looks pretty pretty bad for for
black I think so here you have to look
King G7
but luckily now there's no night on the
board so I have squares for my Bishop
but I'm also not getting
right pretty
so now you have to move uh where does
this guy go
here let's say it's tempo
and so I don't know if I need to go to
different or do I need to activate
your K5 makes sense to me to try to
Target the F2 Pawn because this doesn't
do much
yeah if G4 G5 happens then Rook G8 would
be Checkmate so that that is definitely
a scary plan
that we have to deal with in some way
I guess it's just Perpetual right Rook
F2 King G3 and then we just check on the
second rank yeah because I cannot go
here
yeah so if you checkmate
and then if I go up then it's the same
Raiders Rook G2 and Bishop D2 so again
we walked into unfortunate checkmate
okay so but we know there is this idea
with rookie one so maybe there it's um
so G6 was played
and we're thinking about rookie one here
because this will be a transposition
oh I think Doro yeah Doro has already
played rookie one so he has yeah I I saw
him do it on the okay on the thing
okay so he won Ricky want
is this uh yeah this is what we're
analyzing can you summon rookie and this
is the position we're analyzing
and uh this has to be the best way for
uh White to play because the positions
that we looked at looked very dangerous
for black
yeah I think any position that's a pure
Rook end game where you get that
structure is going to be too dangerous
for black to deal with just too many
mating Nets and
um permanent structural defects because
yeah if tonight's uh
to be a very bad end game actually let's
see why so I check you I go here
and
what do I do here because what's it Rook
C4 might be some kind of a threat
um can we just play Rook G5 anyway
because if Rook G5 Rook C4 I think can I
oh okay you're gonna take my D4 upon of
course but yeah my point was if you
played like Rook C4 which I don't think
you should do then take take and work F5
Maybe
C3 Rook C5 uh
it's unfortunate
and yeah I think I can do this right I
can just constantly harass your Rook
yeah I don't think your rule can go too
far because this point is dangerous
okay so in this position D4 is hanging
so we have to be clever so if I check
you go here
um so if I go to a cafe then I start
collecting your seven rank
so I can take
either way
so I can take with the F Pawn F record
to zero so which one should we try
because if I take this way I'm also
winning
this looks very scary this looks like
it's going to be okay now I'm throwing
mating too oh I was thinking you could
even you could play Rook F6 check also
but yeah that looks better because Rook
G5 is such a huge threat
so if I take
so Rook D2
so it's what four versus two so I'm
losing this Pawn but we can just play
like rookie five and H4 even right give
the F Pawn and bring our Canon I don't
think this end game should be very good
for black yeah because you don't have if
you have the H5 here this would be a
different story yeah but since you don't
yeah this should be just winning because
this Pawn will fall
and this one is also not getting too far
because here you just lose this Pawn
immediately
and this Rook is nicely centralized Rook
date is a huge thread and
um
so it's taking this Pawn yeah this looks
very nice so in the game GTX F5 was
plate so
uh so we're expecting rookie eight okay
so he might
um
you might actually start with a takes
before or okay eight which one oh a
takes B4 yeah might be more forcing
right because you can't defend uh
against rookie at anyway so uh a b Rook
B5 Rook E8 is just a transposition and
there's no there's no need to leave
Knights on the board if we think one
sort of end games so King just
create and live the knights on because
if you take
or no oh because here the bishop could
move so before the bishop would move it
a Tempo so this she takes F5
actually gives white an option to do
this is this anything now here I will
just wait
let's do something off
so if Rook F1
and I try to do this Knight C3 I guess
let's see two and then oh yeah Rook C7
oh my god oh wait
yeah the the next I did I forgot what my
point was with Knight C3 and Knight C3
is pretty nasty move and after you take
here then you go here and then you just
collect everything yeah
so after ethics before so rookie it is a
threat to win a piece so he has to take
so we will see this end game and this
end game actually looks winning for Taro
which would be pretty huge for the
standings because if Dara wins this game
and none of the other leaders win their
game then Dara will be in clear first
and before we go
because looking at this camera's
Benjamin bike and some Savion because
when we had uh what we looked at it
looked so Benjamin was just blitzing out
all the moves looked like it was some
kind of a long preparation so it's some
Bishop versus knight with Pawn against
Pawn so
this Yvonne is telling me evil says that
it's um that it's a draw but the table
base says it's winning and the table
base of course Trump's evaluation but
there's only one winning move but the
winning one is very logical you just
push your pawn and then and the drawing
moves are not so logical but I think the
reason wait
so eight four
five immediately goes up
A5 and I go here
this is the whole idea so because the
idea is you have the wrong Bishop so it
doesn't even matter if you lose all your
all your material in that final position
there's no way for white to make
progress
so Bishop F4 Cuts Black's ability to go
to the corner
um and yeah you just win uh concretely
A6 A7 I believe and once you check me I
think I earned oh wow this is still a
drop wait why doesn't A7 win Knight D5
King C6
I just keep checking you and the second
you let me go
well why are we talking B7 nice
so there is but okay so you have to you
have to overrule the Knight first king
C6 and the bishop and pawn do a nice job
of stopping the king from going to the
corner anyway
if I didn't have this Pawn actually I
could do something like this and this
stalemate
I think this is a job without the pun I
don't think you can win this because
I'll just go oops I just go back and
forth
yeah I think I think that's true no yeah
okay let's imagine I don't have
ah then because I was
because I would still lose but now you
know you can check me from D5 and we
already had this position and I check
you from here wow so having this H7 Pawn
is actually bad for black so I wish they
could take this fan off the board
is this such an obvious so King B6 King
E6 is it so obvious but he has to
calculate this bit until the end because
A4 is the only winning move everything
else is a drug the the nice thing about
this being basically entirely
preparation he has 43 minutes to think
about this position imagine you played a
long game and it wasn't preparation and
you calculated very well and you
achieved this um Theory theoretically
winning end game and you have a minute
left on your clock and he has already
spent 20 minutes so he's already into
trouble it's possible that he is double
checking his lines or maybe he's not
seeing the win and maybe he knows it's a
win and he's just trying to figure out
how to finish the game but here's 45
minutes to make four moves he can just
leave himself a minute and then make the
move do you want to see how we got here
because this must have been some
incredible prep
yeah so we got here let's start from D4
Knight F6 so some kind of a
so is this C5 Catalan very trendy line
these days
and this C to remove which is a key move
because black is going to be losing this
Pawn anyway so might as well just give
it up in a way that destroys uh one's a
white spawn structure because white
would rather have to spawn back on V2
and have the open file for The Rook
yeah what's funny is I think this
position without that structural uh
deficit for white is just like just flat
out bad for black like if you castle and
then Knight C4 I had a game here where I
played like a 2000 USCF player and like
within two moves I was like plus three
with white and it wasn't even like
it didn't seem like it should be that
bad but it is that bad because uh the
difference in quality of the bishop on
G2 versus the bishop on C8 yeah I think
this is one of those things if you don't
sense the danger from early on you just
get in a bad position because you think
what have I done wrong I battle for the
center I develop my pieces and I castled
but this long-term problem of this
bishop is actually devastating for black
because it's not easy to develop this
guy at all because Bishop D7 runs into
what both Bishop G5 maybe even 95 and
the structure starts to fall apart a bit
which is why C3 is a key move and
actually all of this has been played
many times before but in this game in
particular they're following a game from
the 2022
American Cup so we will see where the
deviation was so all of this was still
so uh yeah the user the viewers can also
see it if you look at the time it's 137
which is 135 so they just Blitz and get
out they're not spending any time and
they're actually they have more time
than they started with
by playing this preparation so all of
this is played so this was tingling
around with this so as well
and Ray Robson with some Savion from
last year's American Cup
so we're still following that game so
neither player is um so here actually
Sam spend some time
the other option would have been
capturing with the Knight there's still
some quite high level games here Dean
Lee Ren versus Wesley sobine probably
the highest level game achieved in this
position
so the king comes in at five to seven
is also played or yes Evian already
played this against Robinson as you're
saying so E5 was played and G4 and I
believe this is where I found this game
this is where the deviation was so in
that game King D3 was played and here
white plays G4 which is kind of
incredible and that kind of is really
incredible to find some kind of a
novelty on move 26 and your opponent uh
just this is the kind of thing that I do
I played some line and then my opponent
plays it and I'm like oh great I already
played this I'll just keep just
sometimes I get stubborn and I'll just
repeat a line that I've played before so
he just uh did some really deep
preparation Benjamin park that is
followed this game that some Savion has
played and G4 the engine still says it's
equal but
now we're going to see how we ended up
where we did so if we look at the time
Benjamin Buck he has now 10 minutes
extra than he started with we're
reaching move 30.
yeah so not just blitzing all of this
out so he managed to get uh at least 29
moves of theory on the board if not 30.
I mean not Theory sorry preparation
first time
times into think
because Knight D4 and here F4 is
actually
inaccurate for uh black because it
forces us to go well forces Sam to go
into this bishop versus knight end game
which is possibly hard from afar it's
hard to see that the Knight is just
going to be too far away
and I think
the reason this end game is tempting
so I have three of course this is
untouchable
and one reason this is this might be
tempting because this is the wrong
Bishop so if the king gets to A8 black
has nothing to think about
and
okay he's still thinking about the
position uh with A4 I think we should um
let him think and maybe take a look at
the uh the B group
the standings for the
so
um Oxford Chandra is playing against
Victor mikolesky glove Duran against uh
Balaji dogapati Jason Lane against Kirk
gazerian and dumbassarin versus uh Luca
but our key matchup of course is going
to be Felix against gergely Cantor and
it seems like there's a lot of action
happening in that game right now yeah at
first glance this position just looks
completely lost because uh from
calculate counting correctly why it has
two nights that's not a night that's a
night two nights and a pond for a rook
and the quality of the pieces is not
comparable because these nights are
amazing and this King compared to this
King
uh no comparison and garagalikantor
again is a minute to make
many moves eight moves and his opponent
has 34 minutes and gergilla did survive
that scare yesterday and again today he
finds himself in a very tough situation
it doesn't look like he's going to
survive today it's the same situation
though right um his opponent is on plus
one and he is on plus two and if his
opponent wins this game he will LeapFrog
him so of course uh we got a thumbs up
from our cameraman uh of course he's
gonna try to fight but it it looks like
like an awfully hard fight ahead of him
so let's see how we got here so let's go
so C4 E5
so we have another Fortnight English
uh E4 was played in in a game yesterday
I I believe that was our key matchup it
was uh schwirtz against Savion or or was
it screws against que sera Perez
I don't oh no it was uh yes okay
and this time white selects G3 which I
think is a more classical move than E4
and now we get some kind of a
basically 53 is played we get a reverse
dragon
but the V3 is played
Rook C1 D3 and we'll still get a two
fianchetta Bishops reverse Dragon
position
tonight so black exchange the Bishops
which makes a lot of sense because this
Bishops was Bishop was quite annoying
1084 then I decided to C5
and we see where the action comes so
Rook F6 doesn't care about this Pawn
because Rook H6 Knight F3 E4 looks like
Checkmate that's not can no longer
defend this Pawn
and something like this queen D5 check
would have been very helpful but the
Knight is covering it
so instead instead of taking the pawn
after Rook F6
even Knight F3 preemptively defending
rookia cricket six now E4 is not a
threat because the Knight is still here
perhaps this is a threat now we have to
worry about take Stakes on e4
yeah Bishop C5 seems like it's a huge
threat
so what
wait wait so what is that so Bishop C5
BC bc5 is the intention
before so we take take this looks like
um so Queen B3 check and then Queen at
C3 is that the idea
or queen of seven ah but no you don't
have a knight so I cannot actually go to
H4 okay so Bishop C5 is not that big of
a right here so instead block says G5
and once you play G5 there is no going
back because you're just so committed to
your attack
I really like this before move because
uh opening the square for the queen and
if Knight here then check and some kind
of a blocking so I was wondering if we
have so this move might be dangerous
because Rooker fade
and this will be made yeah it's hard to
stop quinnage too but here taking only
five I think is enough because now there
is no longer if I before to worry about
now this actually might be a threat p7
is hanging
um and of course opening this bishop
like this is going to be very difficult
for black to deal with this bishop is
very strong but instead black plate G5
and G5 this is so committal against this
bishop playing G5 is so scary and it
looks like
um
black paid for this so Knight goes to E6
a really nice move so the idea of G5 is
very straightforward just to go G4 and
Checkmate of course this is not possible
this Knight just cannot move
since that the Knight one to E6 with the
idea is if G4 now what is going to
happen
uh so Knight G5 is not a movie will take
so what's the idea here
oh so maybe you can play maybe you're
not in time I can play Rook takes C6
maybe and if you take on F3 I have
Bishop E5
and if you block well you can't move so
if you play King G8 then I believe
Knight G5 is good enough
collecting the queen on H3 and if you
play Bishop F6 I think I can take
and then um maybe even something like
yeah Knight F4 is should be good enough
and we take on F6 and everything somehow
seems safe at the end of the day thank
you thank you uh so there's no more
attack right there's no it's just it's
so beautiful here
so well calculated variation by by white
yeah Rook C6 removing a key Defender so
actually the king Defender is on the
other side of the board
uh instead in the game he played Bishop
F6 but Rook C6 nonetheless and we will
find ourselves in a very similar line so
Bishop B5
but the idea is that after Bishop B5
then Knight eg5 comes and we're
calculating this before the broadcast
Knight F7 King G7 and Knight H6 we're
considering but simple 95 is also very
strong so even though white is down the
exchange this King once again and this
very terrible Pawn structure whereas
white spawn structure is just perfect
yeah this is the danger with attacking
on on the H file like this with your
rook and your queen like if your attack
doesn't work those pieces like now seem
pretty misplaced like what is the queen
on H5 doing and what is The Rook on H6
doing like all of White's pieces make
sense and black is sort of discordinated
yeah I mean it's a kind of a
straightforward idea right if it works
it works if not then you just compromise
your position too much Bishop B5 so
Knight 20 D5
Knight G5 Queen H5 Queen B2 very strong
move I like this move a lot
so side steps takes Rook takes but now
you form
uh making that F6 was the correct but I
think Knight F6 uh
looks very annoying yeah you can't play
Knight D5 because E4 would win a piece
and you have to be careful where you put
your cane because k9h8 you like to do
but Knight F7 I think would have won
um
yeah yeah and King G7 86 Knight F4 again
yeah this is very annoying
okay so instead in the game two Rook
takes E4
six but but now doesn't have time to
take back because
um
The Rook is hanging so he moves The Rook
but Knight F7 oh Knight F7 wow so the
point is if Queen F3 then Queen h8 and
queen A8 we forgot about the Rook gun on
A8 but
think
I think it's just too much material can
I can I
yeah so I don't think this work right
works right because if I move my queer
like even like dc6 if you play FG I have
FG and your queen is pinned oh that's
unfortunate
so this doesn't work out
um you can also do this and win this
rock oh I didn't see that yeah this is
yeah 907 is such a nice move if you take
the Knight on F7 then there was Knight
E5 which works the Kane and The Rook
which is very straightforward this is
like one of those studies you know you
make a move and no matter where the
pieces move there's a fork with a knife
oh yeah and some kasparian puzzle yeah
domination sort of G7 Knight goes 25
this Knight is amazingly placed Queen is
centralized the five was hanging
from b5's classy move so no C5 there
will always be opposite Roxy one
now you can go see
and you took it so King G2 I'm gonna F5
Queen goes to B6 now Rook C6 is a huge
threat
I'm taking with this Knights are just so
strong so now the Rook can go to C6 I
think the rule can also go to H1 we're
on move 37 and white has half an hour
white has black has 30 seconds but we
had something very similar yesterday so
I think it's still too early to call
this game although I after this move I'm
having a really hard time finding a move
oh maybe Queen F4 I think White's choose
choosing between a whole a whole bunch
of good moves like even Rook C7
simplifying uh we like instead of uh
Rook C6 like Rook C7
um I I don't think that black is happy
about more peace trades these A and B
Pawns in any end game are going to be
pretty strong no I really like rookie
summon
dreams of Knight G3 and I think
the advantages to big and I think yeah I
think this position okay this position
is just winning you just have too much
material you have and that two knights
and three pounds so that's
too many points
and let's jump into another game or clip
two then and Balaji dagaputi and we see
we see something crazy what is going on
here
oh well so H5 is a nice move the queen
on G6 conveniently defends the sorry the
queen on C6 conveniently defends the G6
pawn and H5 is removing the removing the
guard of the F3 Knight
how did we get here so what's the last
move so this looks crazy but what's the
last moves oh that's so unfortunate ah
and maybe his idea was to play here but
actually this move just loses all the
pieces because I
picked this up with a check and then I
picked the Rook up with a check it's
like Checkers this is such a
heartbreaking plunder because this
position looked quite nice for white so
again there's this Knight that's you
know went a little too far from home but
and white is up to pawns so black must
have committed to some kind of an attack
that didn't work out we can take a look
at how we got here
oh another English
a very popular opening at this level I
I'm seeing
27 Carlos and mamajarov that was played
Carlson which is a nun that was played
in 2008
so 92.
wait Carlson and now 2008 no that's not
the match
that must have been Carlson must have
been pretty young in 2008 is up and
coming he wasn't world champion yet yeah
it was
um
it was 15 years ago right
so he was like 15 years old in that
during that game I think his now he's um
okay I believe he's turning 32 this year
so rookie eight uh okay but I keep going
back and forth between this move so this
D5 mode was quite nice and this diagonal
is just going to be too weak
so it takes
when's this Pawn
so Knight goes to C6 takes the takes
okay so why'd you want a pond but there
has to be some compensation on this
diagonal so Rook C8 centralizing Queen
goes back
P5 uh B5 is pretty annoying against this
Knight trying to dominate it
Queen G4 Queen D6
and Knight F3
but now that I see this Knight F3 move
because if the Knight goes on T4 then I
don't D4 it will be very annoying
because it will stop this 92 checks and
kind of close this D file so Rook d8 is
useless which makes me wonder if Rook d8
Maybe
was the Accurate Way of playing because
now the Knight cannot go to f3d4 you're
just playing against the Knight of not
having so many anchor squares and this
Knight actually where is it going I mean
right now I guess we're trying to play
Knight C6 and Knight D4 so yeah Queen C7
stops that so we have to play here and
maybe the Knight goes this way but I
think this is quite annoying maybe I can
go Rook D2 or
oh maybe I don't have to provoke before
I just let your knight be kind of
awkward here
but instead he played B5 so Queen G4 is
nice because tonight is headed to D4 so
he gives up another Pawn
Queen Rook C2 so I I think he thinks
so much thought this attack was just
really strong and White's pieces are
kind of tripping over each other's toes
um and based off the position he has
right now that's probably correct but I
guess uh there's something here for a
white that consolidates
Rook D7 G6 and this is where we see the
blunder but if I don't plunder can I uh
is there a thread can I take this
it's actually question is H5 a threat in
this position
I think I think so
I don't think you have a move after H5
maybe you can try can you play E4 just
to prevent like
um just sorry yeah like Rook D7 and G6
E4 or E4 before Rook D7 even no this
also loses the game somehow right oh
Rook F3 Maybe
no no well because if you have to play
King takes right right
King face is uh I feel like we're
inspired by the previous game okay so
I can't call it five yeah
and did this
yeah but maybe you don't have to go to
can I go somewhere better can I go to
but it doesn't matter right oh no my
Rook is hanging
so I have to go here okay so maybe this
Rook D7 actually was kind of problematic
because it overworked the queen yeah can
we try E4 with without Rook D7 there's a
rook F3 here is also
oh yeah so this Rook D7 might have been
a bit inaccurate yeah E4 is nice just
blocking the diagonal I wanted to grade
five again like wait a minute H5 is
hanging now yeah and now maybe you can't
even consider giving I don't think we
want to do this but like giving up one
time one pawn and trading Queens
I mean certainly you can never be worse
after after E4
because we're up two pawns and giving
one back shouldn't
shouldn't be enough for black to be
better
yeah so let's see what has happened in
the game so far
oh so after Rook fd1 very unfortunate
where it had such a nice position H5
Queen went to G5 Queen F3 and King H3
is there an immediate mate so cringy six
is hanging and
Queen F5 is that I suppose it's possible
but maybe this end game is not so clear
then come back to D7
um
maybe The Rook can pick up a lot of
Pawns let's say you take on F2
uh so now Knight G1 Knight F3 so Knight
G1 Knight F3 is made in three yeah
so let's say it's a nice idea
so I I don't have time for this right
because this is still mate
some version of Arabian meat
yeah I'm always so bad at these uh
nomenclature chest nomenclature when it
comes to mate
so King H3 a plate but I'm sure if black
wants to trade queens or try to
Checkmate this King
because
this is a thread I don't know if Queen
H6 Queen H6 cannot be a threat how can I
defend this Pawn can I play here
so now you're threatening Queen E6 so I
don't have time grenade maybe rookie
seven
is that clever or no because we're key
seven if you play Queen F5 my idea is to
take and go Rook D7
oh no okay but I'm not even threatening
anything no but if you do that then
maybe I have Rook d8 Rick f8 and then um
and then Rook D7
what did you monitor d8 rook f8 and then
Rook D7 and try to get Perpetual somehow
foreign
again no but now you lost the pawn
remember yeah now we're back oh yeah
so but here you have to but here I
cannot
um so now Knight G1 is a threat teenage
four yeah now you have to run
yeah and now maybe you have some kind of
a idea
but I wonder if
we're here
I want to go Rook D6 but I think 91 is
meat
right this is meat yeah it's just mating
one that's a very unusual construction
yeah this nice kind of Checkmate you
play your Black Knight to White's night
starting square and that's checkmate
resetting the resetting the pieces on
the opposite side
so in the game Queen one two F5 so he
went for this end game so
can I go so what is thinking oh he took
yeah they took of course Rook takes this
is kind of silly to compromise the pawn
structure in the Rooks bad on f8 also
let me promote this so we see this and
what did we do we took on A7 right but
maybe there's other possibilities
like I cannot go F4 because now this
route cannot move because again this
checkmate
yeah although maybe we can play F4
followed by King H4 without
um without moving our work from the back
rank like uh it's like you're playing
like you're not the other piece you're
like I play a four and then I play King
H4
no no no no that's fine yeah
yeah but yeah this night jumps are
actually uh
oh wait after Knight D4 I have G4 that's
why it might be okay because Rook h2af
King G3 so not every single one of my
pieces is somehow under attack and I'm
probably just losing material at this
point no White's playing for the win
so what is the position Rook F5 and
white has a tough decision to make if
he's going to give up this Pawn I can't
see why he might play a floor because
it's when you're playing this position
you might feel like if my opponent takes
on
um
f2i I might get made it here right in
this structure so you might just want to
not give this guy up
or here
so here again we have this we have this
um
end game right and Knight versus some
Pawn so if we can trade
all the pawns magically
I've just uh learned that Felix has
defeated gurgly Cantor in uh and now
this this actually changes the standings
quite a bit because
um uh Felix has officially leaped
frogged uh Cantor in the tournament
going from plus one to plus two and
Cantor has now gone from plus two to
plus one
so let's see where we are so we saw all
of this we said this and he played Rook
H1 he decided he doesn't want to trade
he wants to Checkmate Queen F4 was
played Rook H3 simply defending not
allowing any kind of
threads and queen comes to D4 and is
this queen trapped
no but he just picks up another pawn and
is almost captured all of his opponent's
funds and I think so the clock shows
zero but maybe he just to resigned
actually we're in move 41 and I think he
just didn't want to play this position
anymore when you have a bad position
like you said you have no time so you
just play because you have no time
there's nothing Clues but at this point
he just didn't want to play this game
anymore so really nice win by Felix who
is now leading the tournament
and let's take a look at this game let's
see if a decision was made not yet so
we're expecting
um
what are we expecting but is it possible
to go G4 here actually
because if I trade if I trade pawns I'm
quite happy
so let's say you take take you take I
take
you always have to worry about Rick d8
and Rook D7 yeah okay if you take I'll
meet you
and
so night this night is actually kind of
trapped right it's really out of the
game
and if we trade
the problem is tonight we'll go to C3
and defend B5 but if we can trade
if we can yeah if we can trade all the
pawns
um for all of Black's pawns we have four
four to two pawns then probably we're
not losing
so in this position I'm not sure which
one is even important to get but I think
really good fighting
chances like oh he blundered and he's
then he's going to resign which maybe
Queen F5 practically wasn't the best
move although I think
um that actually practically a
I'm not sure if I'm right about this but
practically Queen F5 maybe the easiest
move to play because your king is
compromised you wanna trade Queens so in
that sense you're taking care of that
but maybe you're entering an end game
that is not easy to win I would like if
I was playing this I would not think
this was such an easy to win end game
queen of five feels like a really safe
decision so black is unlikely to lose
the game after Queen F5 but maybe reduce
your winning chances by by some margin
do you want to take a look at the Darrow
game from group a because I'm not we
probably have gotten moves by now
what kind of decision did he make so we
left off around here right no we left
off here no we saw all of this
so we sat there so he went rookie eight
and Knight went to D3 so he left the
knights on
Sarah G8
King went here so we saw all of this
right so okay he's repeating a few times
so we we thought that uh the Knight D6
was interesting right
96 yeah we're calculating something like
this the idea of Rook C7 Knight B7 at
the end being uh quite favorable for
white
and instead he went so even 93 so
claiming you cannot take this Pawn
because
I will take here so I took
Rook get Faith he's going after this one
but this also is like all these
positions feel like a mating net for
black
so King goes to G1 and Knight to H6 wow
defended the F7 fun actually it's
defining all the Pawns
and pawn goes to A4
Rook
um Rook D4 and Rook B5 and this is the
final position oh wow so it feels like
Pluckers actually got away with a lot of
things here
the Knight on H6 is a very funny piece
but it's the best defensive piece
so if I move my Rook to where do I want
to move my rookavana
move it here and then I wanted to start
pushing this Pawn which is not easy
because I want to be able to check okay
he went off to A6 yeah so why can't I
take the pawn on D5 right away and then
return to C3
so if you take this Pawn I will go
here I believe
we've got 97 even
uh what's your threat
so if I take on
okay if I play like Rook any Rook takes
a four
and you take on F5 and then I take on F5
and play like Rook of six yeah because
if you don't have Rook F6 right I'm in
big trouble yeah
yeah but uh this three versus two should
be very easy actually because you'll put
a Pawn on A6 and it's impossible to make
a pass Pawn here
yeah instead
I'm sorry okay A6 so we're asking you
want it instead of night whatever I
played 97 you wanted to go back
and you are up a pawn
but now the position is a bit open can
my Rooks enter the game oh actually this
is happening he took on D5 and we're
going to reach move 40 soon so after
King G7
this is Dario's 40th move I actually can
just have it on some play but I expect
the king
excuse me to go to D7 I don't think the
king will get Adventures here
yeah Kinney six seems like it's just
walking into problems um Knight C7 would
be nice if our Rook wasn't on C7 but uh
yeah it's also just um exposed to Future
Rook checks okay next c35 and
so
oh here's quite a bit of time he has 15
minutes
and now the pawn is hanging
um A5 is also possible
with the idea of Rook B6
um
actually I don't know if they want to go
rugby City but okay now if I was is that
possible can I go here whoops yeah I
think you can install this yeah Rook C5
and then like night somewhere yeah
maybe here can I try to activate a bit
so night before you're going okay one oh
I almost pondered
right
yeah I have to be careful where I put my
cane too because I don't think I want to
give Knight G4 check for free and also
yeah this would be a horrible way for us
to lose the game with white I remember
losing a game like this with white ones
when I was like 1900 I played a I played
a master and I was up like a million
pawns like this and I lost to this like
94 Construction
never again
this night nights are so tricky so maybe
in Knight C3 is the safer move because
it also starts stops not start stops
Rook D1 but uh can I try to activate
perhaps
and
claim that I have a threat
which not 100 sure if this isn't there
but okay if I put my Rook behind upon it
like at least I can claim this is some
kind of achievement and I'm actually
curious to know what is the evaluation
oh wow the evaluation has dropped
significantly so keeping these Knights
on
or it's also possible that you know
that's having a little hint of the
evaluation just really
um changes our
yeah I mean with notes on the board we
had this like Knight D6 trick and
obviously we have the evaluation so it's
much easier for us to come up with uh
with moves than the players during the
game but um
yeah it's always so tricky playing
either side of these positions where
everybody is Keen is so weak and there
are lots of pieces in this open style
position
um well noticeable to take it I mean
this is okay with not a lot of time this
is a scary decision to make do you uh do
you want to look at the bot game since
these players have made move 40
okay so we have reached the position
we're looking at except our Knight was
on F6
and we said King C6 and now the Knight
went on E3 and this is a funny move
because if you're tempted we go here
in a big draw but here he has to find
King C6 which I think he will find
because what else can he do but he
reached move 41 so he gets 30 more
minutes I see King C5 is also winning
which is uh which is a nice move um
there's a
uh like the king uh two uh a square away
diagonally is one of the worst positions
that the Knight can be away from the
King and this is also one of the bad bad
ones because the king like kind of cuts
the the knights path
um
right like you just pass you just pass
you just pass and that means
yes because now I just cannot move I can
I can never move the king because A7 so
now my Knight has to go
somewhere and how do you win this
um
let's see
Maybe
where do you go
maybe so this again right immediately a
draw great
if I ever let you play Knight D5 I think
it's a draw
so let's say if you go here and I go oh
no not here no because here yeah here I
can take yeah
just in general like um oh with a track
we mean okay I understand I mean yeah
well if you've ever played Knight D5 and
I can't take it I think it's a draw
okay so after A6 93 but um King C6 is
easier yeah C5 Sims on this okay so if
you go here and I go here is this
already a win no this is immediately a
drop so you still have to calculate you
still have to find some kind of a
triangulation unfortunately the
database tells me that one two three
four five six seven eight moves are
winning so I think that's most of the
moves in the position
so let's see how we win this so if I
pass
and I check you I have to go King C5
right and then we'll land it where we
are So eventually white has to find a
win
so can I play the move
so
I want to be able to go here because I
can dominate tonight yeah
yeah I really want to dominate the night
somehow but it seems impossible to both
dominate The Knight and stop the king
from coming to to B8
yeah it's still very very very tricky so
if I go back and forth
so how do we dominate a horse
um oh wait wait so if I play Bishop D6
and you play Knight F5 and I play King
C6 and you take me and I go but I don't
take you okay but if you do take me then
A7 wins
but if I don't take you what do I do oh
97. no 97 King C5
um waking came from C5 right
this has to be game over right
yeah yeah okay so I got 97 this is a
very nice trick
so I go King C5 and you go Knight F5 and
now we're back to where we maybe can be
six
takes on D6 A7 and if Knight C4 then
King A6 and no more checks oh that's
right so precise
yeah you have to calculate this and we
need the Knight to be a C7
but the Knight is not getting on C7
yeah how did we do this Knights are very
funny pieces like if uh I like this um
diagonal trick because it's one of the
furthest distances the night can be away
from something
so how did we do this so we went uh so
tonight one two E3 so we went King to
where uh so we went King C6 I think yeah
King C6 because we said King C5 is
winning but it's unnecessary and then um
so we went Knight F5 and then what did
we do we know
we just yeah we passed the Knight E7
then King C5 the Knight F5 then king or
that we passed again
no not this yeah we passed again then
so we waited until 97 and we played
Bishop D6 with a temple but he has to
work this out all on his own which is
tough to do and that's what he's doing
right now so currently he's not at the
board as they have reached move 40. of
course he's spending a lot of time
because if you mess anything up that's
the difference between a half point and
you don't um uh these are the sorts of
positions where it's really worth it to
spend that extra time
um yeah the main point here was yeah if
Knight F5
um any any time the Knight is attacking
the bishop you can just go King B6
and uh hang the bishop because A7 will
make a queen this cannot be right
I know it doesn't feel right because the
night went too far away so the trick is
if we play A7 then you once again have
this Knight before Knight D5 trick
and you will check me forever
Perpetual because if you run away
um I mean this is just a draw already
okay but night City cannot be a good
move because the Knight just goes too
far away and feels like Knight will get
dominated here
so if we go Bishop D6 or yeah Bishop D6
looks really strong you know it's fine
because if I with this configuration if
I come and somehow get your night you
actually I have time to do it because
your king cannot get close to my Pawn
Yeah you can see five but I don't know
how I can trap this night let's see here
Bishop D6
sorry H5 Kinsey six
and then A7 next no matter what
okay so 92 just doesn't feel right
the Knight has to be here so it can give
something well actually here you're not
threatening
even after King C6 you're not after King
C63 I think A7 okay
I think the big point in this end game
is whenever we put the bishop on D6 we
want to play Bishop D6 before the
knights on F5 because obviously we can't
let the Knight take the bishop on D6 but
after we play Bishop D6 and the Knight
goes to F5 we can play
um
uh A7 and it's just checkmate
so here okay here is A7 sorry so here
and and here if you're pushing the pawn
we can just
hang out until
yeah until you play 97. 66 here how did
we do this we passed again
right yeah sure and then and then Bishop
D6 and then whenever the Knight attacks
the bishop we always go King B6 right
right it's King B6 or C6
I thought King B6 because 196 A7 Knight
C4 or k n A6 and it's domination right
I'm so sad I'm just one I mean it's not
just even one move that you uh Queen
with a check after you Queen you're
covering the square right and then Pawn
could never ever go to H2 because
obviously we'll just take it whenever it
ends up on that square
fascinating
yeah these end games are are always uh
worth studying
so tricky with the Knights
it's always so tricky with the knives
but also Knights are quite useless
so let's see how much time he has
already spent uh let's see because he
had a lot down to 19 minutes he achieved
this end game within out like an hour 20
right and that goes to show he spent an
entire hour just trying to make sure
that he doesn't mess up this end game so
he went A4 so on A4 he spent 40 minutes
here he span just two and a half three
minutes
he played this instantly played this
instantly and here he spent wait like he
didn't do this he played King C6 in the
game I believe
yeah King C6 is on the board
on the spots spell spent spelled spend
12 months on this and King C6 is the
winning move so he has found this
and did he did some response okay Knight
F5 only move because A7 is a threat
and unfortunately first time
most moves are winning here except for a
ridiculous moves so
it's a matter if park has found the
winning idea and it's possible that he
might just stumble into it
despite process of elimination I've
definitely had any games that I've won
by not seeing the ideas and just getting
there by accident
I think he has calculated this until
then a very strong Grand Ambassador but
uh very strong Grand Master decided to
spend an hour on the position I think
yeah he he knows what he's doing
and let's go back to our group B I'm
very interested in this end game if any
many developments have happened
oh well many developments have happened
so we'll end it we stopped here so Pawn
was taken Rook d8 so we oh he took
immediately and G4 yeah I think this is
a very reasonable way of playing
so trades white things the more I trade
the better my chances are oh but
um wait this is already a draw if we can
take the H5 Pawn then but how do you do
yeah so I guess
so your idea is that we'll just go Rook
H7 and yeah
wow so it feels the white kind of
very effortlessly so here he had to if
he wanted to win wait what did he play
no this happened if you wanted to win he
had to hang on to this Pawn but maybe he
got a bit worried that they give you to
something like this I mean this is like
with the Rook on p7 your king cutter
this actually can be scary because if I
put my Pawn on A7 I'm just winning yeah
the ones even if the pawn gets to a like
A6 you can't prevent it from getting to
A7 so maybe you're already losing here
just flat out
let's find out
yeah
just a draw wow oh yeah here are Rook H7
you cannot hang on it's a nice safe by
duden yeah first he blunders but you
know keeps um
it's very cool and saves it you're very
mature as you uh have said in earlier
rounds the hardest thing to do is to
readjust like he was winning and then
um well then obviously he was in a lot
of trouble he just like well blundered a
piece and then he had to defend this end
game which he did with very seemingly
very little effort I think not letting
one mistake turn into many many mistakes
is what can save you a lot of games and
I it's a very emotional thing I think
and for I think less experienced players
because they just get tilted very easily
and they just completely lose control
like they will blunder a piece and one
stop and think about okay I wonder at
least maybe I still have two pawns it's
not the end of the world oh and also
like I've also seen with more beginner
students they'll win a queen and then
they give up a bishop then another
bishop and I'm like okay but you see how
you they'll be like oh but I'm still up
with queen I'm like okay but you're
losing more and more materials and you
won't be able to three Bishops and two
Rooks in four nights
and we do have a result in group a
Benjamin gildura has won his game wow
this looks very dominating with this
looks like what does it look like one
two three four five up upon but black
cannot win the six is coming with mate
if you play Bishop E7
then rookie one and you just cannot move
any pieces this is such a strong
domination
and
hopefully we will have him here for an
interview and he can take us through
this game we haven't had a chance to
look at it
and
I think the gaming group we were looking
at
so this game maybe he will try to play
another versus Bishop but okay I don't
expect this to be much so I got the news
that godura has left so let's take a
look at what happened
so Bishop C4 Italian and D6 is not a
move we see very often quite a passive
move liking the bishop in
another 54. this looks like one of those
um
morphe games you can say I'm not a big
fan of this D6 idea uh without the
bishop coming to C5 in e45 positions
so 94 is a threat so C3 was played
Knight F6 D3 all of this makes sense
Knight bd2
so the normal Italian positions except
the bishop is out and the bishop is only
seven so I think the idea is maybe to go
G5
oh 27
but you know I I respect this why don't
you just you know you just start an
attack
uh this is quite comedy and I think you
do want to wait for rookie one to do
this because as it happened so Queen
design he is preparing to Castle so it's
not like you know he's just closes his
eyes and just pushes his Pawn so you are
getting ready you know black is not
hiding his intentions I think Bishop H5
was very clear he wants to go
um
G5 because also I think if you start
with this move can I be completely
Shameless
no
we'll take care after
um G4 I think maybe would black
sacrifice a piece in that position
because I really don't like the bishop
on G6 like positionally like if after H3
Bishop H5 G4 Bishop G6 if I play like
Knight H2 or whatever I think The
Bishop's stuck on G6
I don't know
like winter capablanca kind of
situations but uh no here I think I can
just
because you're not really pinning me
right this is so defended I don't think
I'll get married here but it's not my
position so okay I will happily play
this no I think here um I'll just move
away move this queen Knight H2 it just
you don't have a way of getting your
pieces in which is a problem yeah but if
you after G4 Bishop G6 isn't Black's
Bishop on G6 like a little stuck
but you know you have hope that one day
you can move
into a play and like
and like to be very I would be very
scared to do this in an actual game
because you move your knight and I go D5
it just uh I mean you know your Castle
you go H3 G4 and your opponent hasn't
castled that's fair yeah I wanted to
just um
just show it but uh so but no I think I
understand this idea is to play
and this position has been played before
so usually black castles but Bishop H5
you just want to go here here and just
push your Pawn all the way to G3
and so rookie one and you want to wait
and for rookie one the point I was
trying to make is because G5 G4 the
Knight cannot go to E1 so the Knight has
to go to H4 which I'm not sure is so bad
because the Knight Will blend to F5 so
let's just see how the game develops so
it goes G3 and the point being if you
don't go to G3 let's say you make
another move and I play this Knight H4 I
believe you take here and then this guy
is hanging because if this guy is not
hanging if I put a knight on F5 this is
just so bad for black wait
yeah I was I was thinking G3 might also
be interesting but maybe here I don't
know if I'm so scared of jittery I
really want to put an I don't have five
right yeah the Knight on F5 looks pretty
good but he want G3 to just stop all of
this which is very reasonable move
because after so G4 is very communal for
black because once you go G4 I put a
knight on H4 it just kind of stops your
attack because physically you don't have
H5 H1 just physically stopping this pump
from moving and next I put a knight on
F5 maybe not even the Knight on H4 like
you could go Knight D2 Knight E3 Knight
F5 and there are lots of knights coming
in position
this is quite scary
so black doesn't commit to this
immediately castles A4 and the white
attack here is very straightforward just
push pawns I like this kind of things
where your attack is very simple you
just push your palms so Bishop goes back
doesn't want to open the position as I
think this might lead to
a lot of play for black and women okay
now here C3 is hanging F5 V4 is coming
this
this is not great so we want to keep the
position close so Rook G8 Queen C2
I mean I have to say this looks kind of
scary but like this is one of those
positions I don't know if white is
getting made it or black is just over
committing and nothing is going to
happen
so Rook G6 we already saw this idea in a
game that did not work out so now he
opens the position gives up his Bishop
wow so this is very concrete yeah and I
think what is going to happen if you
take then we take the Knight right and
then the bishop goes where if you go
somewhere then we can maybe take UMBC oh
you want to do it the other way I was
going to take on B7 but the point that
you can't recapture
um yeah you have to go King B8 because I
also think I put my Bishop in the worst
possible score because I dropped my own
Rook at least I should put my Bishop to
you seven but okay this might actually
not be so bad maybe the king
it's hard to say the king will hide here
but it's possible
have two Bishops
but I'm in this this is very awkward
instead he plays E4 with the idea so if
you play D takes maybe you want some
yeah Rook D2 is what I was thinking okay
if I take here this is game over and if
I take with the Knight what do you want
to do maybe Rook H6
and then my ideas Bishop E2 so if you
take my knight on C6 Bishop E2 or E2 I
think I Checkmate U
I'm not totally sure
why to stop it I have a check and that's
it
so this is again Unstoppable
and no I'm not sure
I didn't see that
it's uh sometimes I stumble into things
this is actually a very funny way of
defending this Checkmate but Bishop D2
is a really nice move because you're
taking away this oh actually maybe ah no
you can just go Bishop G4 here right
why play complicated when you could play
Simple
oh my God wait wait a second wait wait a
second I just realized something and
where was the night uh can I play it
takes H2 and then Bishop F3 the classic
that would be very nice of course why
yeah why play Simple when you could play
complicated
but uh
okay so he attacks with the Rook doesn't
want to allow any of those things and G4
okay so this is starting to look a bit
scary
I like this move because yeah so if you
took the Knight on C6 right away then G
takes F3 is Unstoppable Checkmate so you
have to get rid of your knight being on
F3 because the black pawn arriving on
the F3 square is too much for what to
deal with
it's really annoying when your own
pieces get in the way of your attack
because of this bishop but the thing is
now without this light Square Bishop
even if I let you take it my King has an
Escape Route so Bishop went back
so it takes B7 now you cannot take
and Rook F1
I look F1
so I guess as defensive intention is F4
and you just wanted to be able to
recapture when the pawn comes to F3
might be might be an oversimplification
no I think that's exactly it
um I thought but okay again not my game
I'm happy to give up this H to pawn it
he doesn't want to do it no this is very
straightforward Rook D3 the queen is
overworked we cannot take it uh Bishop
C1 such a nice move attacking this guy
Rook D6 uh why not rock H5 because
hmm
push about four maybe still and just
kind of ignore everything
yeah after he was hanging there so what
happens if Rook here maybe Rook F2
just saying your Rook is hanging now but
I didn't know officially
oh okay actually
yeah this is becoming scarier than it
should have been can I take on G4 first
yes
um and now maybe Rook f
I know Rook f8 you play Rook D1 and
maybe
yeah I don't want to even calculate that
yeah that actually looks quite bad uh so
what do we do here I mean Rook D4 is a
very reasonable move here
so I think my claim is also like your
queen is just completely out of the game
and every end game is good for white
because of the material and also the
difference and quality of the bishop so
Queen G2 might be a serious threat
fade it's also pretty
big so instead he went Rook D6 change of
Gears but now Bishop comes with a tempo
so trades and Rook D4 okay so Rook D4
it was a strong idea and I think here
you may not and now we see the queen
desired again and I think this actually
um you're the one getting attacked but
no there's Bishop B7 still but maybe
Queen D5 or no can I go after this Pawn
Quincy too your queen is just so useless
right it's just other side of the board
yeah Queen C2 is very nice it stops
Bishop C5 and attacks the C7 Pawn
until
we give eventually yeah Bishop d8 Queen
G8 might just win a piece yeah coins are
queen D5 also yeah yeah all of this very
strong so instead he decides to bring
the coin back
but now the tables have turned and this
bishop as we saw
doesn't come back excuse me so yeah it
doesn't want to take on C6 because now
you just won't be able to move on Rook
Divine just drops the bishop
instead he went rookie one but the coins
come off and here he resigned right
after 360 resigned because uh D6 is
coming and actually Rook C1 and 6 is
coming plug just simply cannot move
do you want to check back in with uh
with Benjamin see if he's found
everything so we're getting pretty close
to the position that we analyzed
straight so black decided to play H5
as opposed to Knight F5
um the point being
um black doesn't really want to play
Knight F5 because as soon as you do that
we uh it's funny you think well you're
attacking the bishop so the king must
stay there but actually we will undefend
our Bishop and play the move King B6 but
in the previous position and uh instead
of playing
um well okay I guess yeah so if if you
play uh King B6 in this position then
black will play Knight D5
so the Knight actually has to stay on E7
to prevent King B6
don't think he will plunder this but
still he needs to find
um
this he well he still needs to find his
idea right at Knight F5 King B6 so he
just has to wait with the bishop it has
to make sure that he's not wandering
anything in the way as he does it but I
think this one I think he's already
found it I would think yeah I actually
expect this game to be over pretty soon
well last time we said that
let's see what's happening in this game
oh so so we did reach move 40 so the
players are thinking oh wow actually
black
has not made a move so after rookie five
black has not made a move in this
position he has been thinking since
getting his excuse me extra 30 minutes
and
um
excuse me
what's going on here
B6 is a possibility or because rookie7
is not a threat
uh rugby six maybe Knight B5 is the idea
and now I can go back or I can go okay
too
I really want to get my Rooks into the
game
if Knight C3 I can pin this will be
pretty annoying
but okay if not Rook P6 what else can we
do
is possible
um what else what else maybe Rook C3
here
with the idea of taking A4 even right
yeah
there we go
and also threatening group D6 and if you
do something like this then Rook D6
yeah boy needs to be careful that his
second Rank and back crank don't become
weak uh black is not without his own
threats
you go here I wanted to go here
with the idea of mate
it actually starts to look dangerous you
go here maybe before maybe after rookie
six I can play Knight E4
I don't like Rook C5 Rook E6 94 is my
like tactical idea but maybe you just
like go away and then Knight F2 you ever
q1 and Knight G4 yeah yeah
this would be a bad way to lose the game
we have fun anyway so what's the game oh
he did Play Roxy too oh that makes me
feel good
unless it well just drops immediately
like Rook city was run or Splendor ever
yeah playing like yesterday Perez is not
not a bad person to play like
wait so I'm his clock went up to 34
again oh so he probably I think the way
these clocks work like you have to flag
for your 30 minutes to be added yeah
actually or you have to make a movement
I think that's how most most clocks work
at least in the US is that it waits
until your clock uh completely goes down
to zero and then it adds the extra 30
minutes okay so if I'm looking correctly
in move 37 is 15 minutes no that's not
37 what am I doing 38 he has 15 minutes
he has 15 minutes
he has 13 minutes and now he has 34
minutes so he spent 20 minutes which is
a reasonable 41. although a lot of
mistakes do happen on the 41 you know
you start to think and then you
overthink you make a mistake I think it
has a lot to do with like changing gears
right like you're you're playing in this
like Blitz mode and then all of a sudden
you need to you need to think again and
uh you can run it I've done both things
where I've moved too fast at move 41
because I I was in time pressure now I'm
not and also I've done the reverse where
I immediately put myself in high
pressure again
41 was the only time I could think there
is no right way of making them 41
hopefully it's a force move so I just
make it and then you can get over it
yeah these things are so tricky because
like I've also made it that move 40 I've
made some kind of uh
like a move that kind of changed the
character of the position and then reach
move 41 I'm like oh why did I do that
when I just reached time control and
think like a normal person
but uh yeah this change of Gears any
kind of change of Gears I think is very
tough to do in chess there's a lot of
games we haven't looked at uh so in
group b this game that we're looking at
um this is now Rook Knight versus Rook
black will try for a very long time
let's see when was the last capture last
capture was move 49 so we can go until
move 99 40 more moves to go but these
are pretty simple draws yeah I mean
gloved is a very very strong
International Master it's uh probably
should be a grand master soon so we we
don't expect these sorts of players to
mess up these end games but it does
happen so he still needs to
play accurately
so let's see what else we have here so
we had one result here so Felix won so
we expect this game to be
um a drum let's see this actual Chandra
game versus
michalevsky so akshat is seems to be
doing quite well yeah actually I could
also type her first I think he's on plus
one one right now and um he's about to
beat somebody on the same uh score group
as him
so let's count material one two three
four one two three
um yeah the naked King so we reached we
are moved uh so last movie took on G7 so
we are on move 42 and actually let's see
the time situation so he reached us with
a one minute on the clock
and 16 minutes and he's thinking so I
don't think it's going to be in a rush
there was a problem here the king of
course and this Rook cannot move because
um Queen G5 is coming yeah you can't
move any of your pieces right like if
you move your queen then maybe Knight F3
will come because The Queen Is
preventing the Knight on H4 from moving
The Rook can't move because the queen
will come to G5
uh uh and um yeah I want to play the
move Rook F6 here I don't know
the computer thinks of that but can I I
wanted to take it immediately it says
yeah I think I think all your pieces are
just Frozen yeah that's very unfortunate
but uh White has to wait but for example
if I play here immediately this is so
bad right because I just take away all
the ideas right yeah so it's actually
timof he had a winning position
yesterday unfortunately he did let go of
that win so I think today he will really
want to win this game to make up for it
and looks like he is doing really well
here so I think there's quite a few
moves for cap6 maybe I think from a
psychological perspective is really
important after you blow a win until it
to um win your next game or the very
least not lose because it's so easy to
be like ugh I I should have won this
game and then you draw and afterwards
you just don't play very well because
you were like well what should have been
and you just have to be in the moment
the Tilt The Tilt is too real and just
what else do we have going in this um so
have a look at all the games so this one
was I'm just going one by one so this is
not a game we have seen
so we see another opposite color tuition
color visual position okay so um yeah
probably right we should be taken and
so it looks like
looks like one of the spawns is going to
fall right so this is hanging so we will
take wait I'm I'm curious oh that's
actually so what what were we doing
against Kane E8 instead of Kane f8 so we
went to like attack The Rook on D7
so we just capture the Pawns
so I think this is very bad right
because I think here you lose both
pieces which is really funny just by
capturing upon how everything is hanging
um so what do I have to do so I have to
give up this um wait C7 is it this is
seven no chicken C7 is a big threat
actually so I have to
fight against that let's say I go here
you take maybe I take and
no again this should be five
yeah
but then I have to defend this end game
so actually really funny right at Rook
D7 king of f8 because you because you
would think okay I'm up a piece I have
it's more important to save your pawns
than your piece in this instant I
suppose so King went to a fate
um I don't think
something black wants to do because now
I will win this Pawn
so white wants to keep this tension so
it wants to take and now I can either
take no I can take this and the next
move in this Pawn
I think or I can take on B7 and next
move when on B5 I don't know which one
is more annoying I kind of like the
reverse because I might not even take
the B5 Pawn like I'll play Rook B7 and
then C6 C7 comes to mind as an idea yeah
this actually might become very concrete
right because maybe I want to just win
by pushing my pawn and Bishop B5 might
be a loss of tempo
um
long term there's this wrong Bishop but
I think that it's so far away
and also if this Pawn ever moves Bishop
C4 with the idea for F7 will be
devastating so this actually looks very
scary because this Pond is running at
the list and I also again want to take
and maybe it's like the bishop back to
C4 so if I
so for example if I go here it might
actually already be lost right yeah I'm
not sure how I'm going to defend this so
I have to go here my idea is 67 at least
I can
so my point is to cover the speed square
because this was the idea
and
but maybe we can um
reverse the order somehow like if I play
Rook D7 or I'm in like C6 Bishop B5 Rook
D7 you probably have to go to A8 anyway
because I'm threatening C7 Rick d8 so if
you go to A8 then I take on B5 and
um no but I think he will just go see
some rc7 anyway yes special D4 is a very
silly movement here because I'm just
provoking the movie you want to play
anyway so I already have to think about
how to stop this Pawn so maybe already
Bishop B5 but it should be five maybe
you have F4
yeah and you definitely want to be able
to play Bishop E5 at some Moment In Time
put the rook and found upon and but this
looks extremely unpleasant but if I
do this
because Bishop C4 I take and if you go
C6 then I'm just always attacking this
and then although even this position
looks very unpleasant yeah but the point
is if you but maybe oh but now
happy to make a four or something or put
a bishop on C7 that was my idea oh well
wait so after Bishop E5 F4 uh you have
to go to D6 right because if you go
Bishop C7 now maybe bishop C4 is
annoying
but um
then Rick
yeah
Rook F7 Rook G7
oh I cannot no I should be fine oh I
didn't I didn't see okay but still I
lost quite a few pounds so this is quite
unpleasant okay so Jason Liang
in a driver's seat doing really well so
he took on it too so he's going to be
pressing for a very long time it has the
potential to be a very bloody round in
in both sections actually and there's
one more game that this is three versus
two uh not the easiest uh oh it's
Bishops Bishop versus knight right yeah
there's a lot of visual versus Knights
here and this knight uh not a very happy
night so this night is actually quite
dominated so maybe
so what is White's idea I want to play
here on June no well if you move your
king if you start get a smooth like a
bit senseless something like this
already
or maybe bishop F4
now I have to calculate a lot
it's
yeah did I find the draw yeah because
F's oh no I have G5 oh yeah
just in time I can actually Queen
and King here
okay but in this position that we have
to making so many crazy moves um
this night is actually quite dominated
and I need my Bishop where do I need my
Bishop I think I Bishop on before I
think
but some not such an easy win for uh for
white not not easy to make progress like
I want to put
uh I think it's going to be some kind of
a zuccher one because at some point I
will put a king here and then go F4 and
then you will start running out of moves
what do you think of the idea of playing
the move Bishop to C1 with the point
being that if you go Knight F1 I want to
play the move Bishop F4 yeah this is
you're just completely dominated so this
will be his looks among at some point
you will bring your king
I don't know which way you want to bring
your king but yeah every time you play
G3 I'll meet that with Bishop c one yeah
just making sure that if yeah you never
have King E3
yeah this is
for the defense so before we take a look
at the standings let's see if we have
any development so in this game in
arcade matchup in group a looks like we
are reaching more a trash territory
after Rook C2
H3 was played to stop this Knight G4
move he probably was worried about it
and giving up this pawn and Knight B6 I
think white can perhaps still try
against this font structure but once the
King goes to G6 and it's not on H6 such
a great piece yeah we think of like good
pieces and chess as those pieces that
have like lots of moves to go to but if
a piece like serves a very important
function then why isn't it a good piece
the Knight on H6 serves a very important
function just defending every Pawn on
the board such a great night and maybe
at some point we can bring it into the
game and Benjamin bug versus some Savion
uh
I did this position yeah we had this in
analysis and we played Bishop H2 I
believe but I think this is the final
last position we saw right I don't think
he has moved since
because isn't this the like last time we
checked this game was in a disposition
or they made this one was on H5 last
time we saw but so what happened so
Bishop patio and I just said okay so
he's just shuffling so Bishop BC so he
did find this idea that 97 is met with
Bishop D6 and Knight F5 runs into this
so I think it's just a matter of being
accurate and
all of this bishop wolves will win and I
I think he's going to convert this I
think his fund idea is just a matter of
being accurate and making sure he
doesn't let anything go yeah Ben I mean
Bach will certainly be very pleased if
he wins this game I mean first of all he
will be one of the tournament leaders
and I think he will come back to 50 but
also this might be a perfect game of
chess like if he played he played all
prep and then his opponent made a
mistake and if he wins he converted a
theoretically winning position like what
more could you want from a game of chess
nah and he didn't exert that much energy
because he spent most of it was prep and
we can take a quick look in the other
positions so this game
uh between Daniel Darda and Abu Manu
Mishra also looks quite even even though
there can be past pan but not enough
pieces not enough pants on the board I
would expect this to end in a draw yeah
Christopher Ilya was already a drawer
yes this was this ended before we
started our broadcast
and yeah fascinating round I this game
which is of Benjamin back and some
Savion what a prep what a game what a
way to win a game to remove some prep
and then a bishop versus knight end game
and it's really fascinating what chess
is at a high level of um you know when
we think type long prep it's not like
some kind of an attack or something it's
just a bishop versus knight and you know
letting your opponent to figure out how
to defend and you're figuring out some
kind of a theoretical domination about
Bishop versus a knight yeah it's very
rare that you get to prepare something
you're like oh I prepare a win it's like
oh you have some crushing attack no the
win is that I have Bishop versus knight
table base win yeah something something
else
and let's take a look at the standings
let's see where we are and uh we have
just two results so far in group a
Christopher U and ilianuznick drawing
the game which puts Christopher you half
a point ahead of the pack with three
points and Benjamin gladura did win his
game and he's at two and a half points
only half a point behind the leaders and
uh we're expecting Taro and quesada to
also draw their games which means they
will join Christopher you in the lead
and some Savion after he loses as we
expect him to he will fall behind the
letters by half a point and will be
joined by Benjamin bogg and in group b
we have Felix blubberger who defeated
kirgo encounter and so far that's the
only result we have but we do expect
aksha Chandra to win his game so he
should be able to catch up with um uh
with uh with Felix after this round so
we expect there to be two leaders going
into round number six
to win and you know after yesterday's
game I'm actually rooting for him
because I just know what it feels like I
think every child's players knows what
it feels like to miss a win in time
travel it's very painful and this has
been another fascinating rant thank you
everyone for joining us on this Easter
Sunday and we will see you tomorrow at
the same time have a good one
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited